The first man to smoke marijuana.
Never really smoked it.
He inhaled it.
He was a Chinese man.
He was a very great man and whenever he lit the,
the plant,
it wasn't to get high,
but he would start to get high and every time he got high a blue bird would come
to him.
Chicken canned food.
Chilled water.
Ha ha ha ha.
Cool.
Have you ever been to Disneyland?
I mostly live in La.
You know what?
Fuck California.
Go and try living in the woods by yourself for a while.
Saw Him on Milan kid.
Why are we doing this?
It's crazy.
I just took,
it was a civil war starting today.
I don't want to jump the gun on that.
I got pistol whipped with
the gun to the head.
Nothing blood.
Thank God.
But if fucked him hurt and I looked at them like,
what are you crazy like I don't even what to know what the fuck you guys are
doing?
Yeah.
The way the tie was hitting the speeds,
like the how fast they were going up hill.
I mean,
I think at Tesla.
Yeah,
it's the most fun thing you could possibly buy ever.
The first 30 minutes of that,
like I told I was going to die,
I try to convince people to slow down is just mind blowing.
I wouldn't recommend it,
but even in Turkey we lose our fucking minds.
My friend who I kidnapped showed up.
That would cause a lot of trouble.
He was the king of me too.
This is also true of Facebook.
I saw a movie chimpanzee.
Yeah.
That was gonna be like some days anything.
I was like,
holy cow Bro.
That movies like a porn,
damn.
These chimps are,
are mean to wow was on the monkey bars and they kill each other and they torture
each other.
That's pretty bad.
Um,
the hundred monkeys that's stuck.
I light porn.
Uh,
I,
I don't want to sound like,
like thanks for too dark.
The universe as we know,
it's will dissipate into a fine mist.
Yeah.
Of Cold.
Nothing.
This is,
what the fuck is this.
I'm not that good looking and I am not happy,
so I'm a suck bro.
I think best case scenario,
we
effectively emerge with Ai.
We get the fuck up before I fucking kill you.
You dumb motherfucker.
No,
no,
definitely not.
Definitely not.
I was good.
I would cause a lot of trouble sleeping in the garage.
No dinner.
This is not a wise move.
We should not do this.
It's very dangerous.
Why?
Okay,
fuck you motherfucker.
I wouldn't recommend it but,
and that would be probably a safer way to go about things.
Go home you a little giddy flux.
You know it's just a hole in the ground.
Go home you little Guinea.
Fuck.
I know I can rock and roll.
I could throw down on seventh street but it's got to be seven straight.
None.
No.
Get up the P two times.
Cause once you're 50 it could be up and down.
I'm not sure what you mean by that.
Well I've been a specialist on asleep since day one [inaudible] so my mom would
wake me up.
I read night at three 30 in the morning with a Cuban sandwich.
You know the things they need to be,
things that make you look forward to waking up in the morning.
He would wake up in the morning.
You look forward to the day before to the future.
I did cocaine for 30 years.
It's probably not wise.
I've been in the fuck another dimension since last week and I don't give a fuck.
It's not necessarily bad.
Okay.
It's just how many people really try to assassinate Kevin Hart with weapons?
I tried for years.
He's just a creepy fucking dude.
That's true.
That mother stone called rape me.
He became friends with this dude.
They had a cat and they started raping them.
Sort of primal drives.
There won't be an outcry.
There will be an investigation.
Years will pass.
There will be some sort of insights committee.
They will be rulemaking.
Then there will be oversight.
Eventually regulations.
This all takes many years.
I was polishing the flux in the the musket.
This is very exciting.
Every day is think of one and put a gun to his side.
Do I know what's going on?
Pat Them in the back and he giggles and shit cause I'm too weighty on tip toe
went up to him.
He don't even hear me in bushes or nothing like that.
That's how good I am and I don't even know.
I've never trained him Quantico,
and then this guy ended up dying at age.
I'm real life bad.
Your biological self dies.
You can just probably just upload into a new unit.
Are you fucking nuts?
Yeah,
pretty much.
I go,
what the fuck am I doing sitting here?
That's what's few tile.
What are you going to do?